hey everyone Joey here with yet again
another unboxing this time for the Mass
Effect collector's edition Nomad MD one
now this version is the remote
controlled version which will cost you
roughly around two hundred dollars for
the non remote controlled version only
about a hundred now if you're excited
for mass spec Dundrum that we'll have
our review up on March 20th as well as
GameSpot Studios which is our
documentary behind-the-scenes look at
the game but for now let's try to open
this box the countdown oh whoa five five
Oh tempest right there educate feel
almost gone oh pretty big alright let's
take this up Andy
pretty hefty it's not as a meticulously
wrapped in plastic like in most
collector's editions are but may I not
shoddy it's actually very got some
weight to it there's the USB cable is a
micro USB oh I got something else in
there got the fuel book version of the
game which consuming
oh don't seal it all right so this comes
with once again the car
Mass Effect Andromeda steelbook okay
uh-huh
sound it they not included and we're
gonna include Oh or in French which is
is you know complete I think let's see
there's one more little insert in our
game in Texas all right do we have to
charge the car before we start playing
with it important answers
step one turn on your Nomad MD one
remote-controlled vehicle all right
let's do this
oh there it is it underneath a little
flat on the bottom to just push in what
I think so when top and bottom headlamps
stop blinking which they are right now
the vehicle is ready preparing well
controller this is kind of similar to
the bb-8 toy that was released a couple
years ago for the force awakens which
you can just remotely control using an
app on your phone have they stopped
blinking all right now we can go to my
Wi-Fi settings on my phone and what you
can do is you can you'll be able to and
connect to Nomad MD 169 a 4g 9 success
oh yeah go back to the app when
connected launch the Nomad MD 1 app and
then you can test connect on the top
left of the screen
yeah hello ah Nomad one would like to
use access to your photos here why not I
have nothing to hide would like your
social security number
all right let's see what this baby can
do
so this thing is actually pretty quick
the app itself when you control you can
either go other words back or left and
right uh see the tires they are moving
just like a real car like a real car
okay now down five four three
oh wow making sure the tires are
[Music]
okay watch wavicles I know something
else in Spain can do there is a little
eye icon which I assume don't tell me
the thing also takes pictures oh my god
this thing has a built-in camera I'm
assuming it's right in the front right
here I'm not sure what kind of
application that has as far as the oh my
god
yeah we send it out yeah
are you trick bang a thief trying to
like super delayed
[Music]
this is William
[Music]
all right and that's everything that's
in the Mass Effect Andromeda Nomad nd
one remote-controlled collector's
edition so a fun little diversion since
you don't actually have the game yet but
when that does come out we'll have the
review on March 20th and if you like
these unboxings one see more to
subscribe to our channel on YouTube
thanks for watching
[Music]